Hey, this is Presh Talwalkar, and you're watching "Mind Your Decisions".
I want to thank Omer from Israel for suggesting this type of puzzle.
A, B and C play a series of one-on-one basketball games.
In a given game, two of them play against each other while the third person rests.
The loser of the game then goes to rest while the winner continues to play,
facing off against the person who just rested.
After they were done, here is how many games each person played
A played in 8 games, B played in 11 games, C played in 15 games
The puzzle is: Who lost the fourth game?
This seems like it will be impossible to figure out, but there is just enough information
Can you figure it out? Give this problem a try and when you're ready keep watching the video for a solution.
So, let's start out with the number of games each person played.
The first step is to figure out how many games were played in total.
Since each game involves 2 people, if we add up the games played by each person,
We will double count the total number of games.
In other words, the sum of the games listed above is 2 times the total number of games played.
So 2 times the total number of games played is equal to 8 plus 11 plus 15.
We can solve that the number of games played is then one half of 34, which is equal to 17.
So how does that help us?
Well now, let's consider the minimum number of games played.
A person that loses every single game must still play every other game.
This is because the loser and the resting player rotate with each other.
So a person playing in game 1, and then losing all games, will play in all odd-numbered games.
This is a total of 9 games.
Similarly, a person playing in game 2, and then losing all games, will play in all even-numbered games.
This will be a total of 8 games.
Now notice, A played in exactly 8 games.
Logically, 8 games is the minimum number of games a person can play.
Since A played in 8 games, we can conclude A played and lost in all of the even-numbered games.
Thus, A lost the fourth game.
Amazing!
Did you figure it out?
Thanks for watching!
These math videos, which can be watched for free, inspire and build confidence for people around the world,
and they already have over a hundred million views.
With your help, we can share the beauty of mathematics and make the world a better place.
Please subscribe for free to get the newest videos, watch and share all of "Mind Your Decisions" videos.
Email me a puzzle or math topic presh [at] mindyourdecisions [dot] com
If you so choose, you can check out my books, which are listed in the video description,
and you can support me on Patreon to earn exclusive rewards.
Thanks for watching and thanks for your support.